este nuevo día en este parqueadero de
sap orilla trae nuevas historias y
nuevas personas que han huido del sur
del país en las tres últimas horas no
solamente de mariupol sino que siguen
llegando personas de otras ciudades en
control de las fuerzas rusas y las
historias que cuentan son exactamente
igual de dramáticas de aquellas que
vienen de mariupol y siguen contando la
tragedia que se vive en esos retenes 17
que tienen que pasar antes de llegar
hacia mar igual esta mañana nos contaba
una madre con sus dos hijas que
estuvieron diez horas y media en uno de
esos retenes llegaron en un momento
muchísimos militares rusos cogieron a
dos hombres los hicieron cavar sus
tumbas y se los llevaron al monte
solamente uno de ellos regresó no saben
cuál es el destino de otros pero estas
son las historias que cuentan las
personas sobre el drama que viven al
llegar al huir hasta acá no solamente lo
que han vivido las últimas semanas sino
también de lo que han sido testigos en
estas últimas horas mientras que logran
llegar a este destino